pour la boutade le 13 mars j'ai reçu les
plans d'un projet d'un avant projet
simplifié que ma maîtrise d'ouvragé
m'avait envoyé par mail qui devait nous
permettre de déposer un permis de
construire pour l'extension de notre
cité ans devait reprendre 2500 m²
supplémentaires
et c'est un projet qu'on a complètement
bloqué ces blocs et reportée aujourd'hui
je dirais que c'est bloqué pour une
durée que je ne connais pas remettre ce
projet à l'ordre du jour sera important
avant la fin de la crise parce que si
l'activité reprend dans les proportions
l'a connu sur le premier trimestre on
sera bloqué pour produire donc il faudra
qu'on s'y prépare à retrouver alors je
suis pas je suis pas optimiste en fait
je suis chef d'entreprise
donc je dois parier je dois avoir des
projets je dois écouter mes clients et
je dois arriver à prévoir ce que je peux
faire demain et en fait c'est pas je
prévois si je prépare ce que je vais
faire demain est forcément un chef
d'entreprise ça prend des risques ça
fait des paris est aujourd'hui la vision
on ne l'a pas mais je sais une seule
chose c'est que si l'activité redémarre
gilles faut que je sois prêt
travail sur combien de jours et comment
ça fonctionnait avant avant on avait 25
jours de visibilité de travail devant
nous aujourd'hui on oscille entre 5 et 8
jours c'est difficile à gérer c'est très
compliqué c'est très compliqué parce que
nos clients qui sont des entreprises
plus importantes que nous ne savent plus
nous dire ce qu'on va voir dans deux
jours donc si on réduit trop la voilure
le risque c'est qu'on ne puisse plus les
servir et si on
on ne leur réduit pas assez c'est qu'on
a une charge financière qui est trop
présente
donc c'est un exercice très périlleux
qui se dessine chaque jour chaque jour
une décision est prise et qui peut être
remise en question lendemain la
souplesse d'une pme l'agilité d'une pme
c'est des mots un peu galvaudé qu'on
entend beaucoup mais qui sont une vraie
réalité aujourd'hui une équipe de
collaborateurs sur qui on peut compter
des gens qui sont capables du jour au
lendemain de venir ou de ne pas venir
alors qu'on leur avait dit contraire la
veille et après une écoute client pour
pouvoir répondre à des urgences de plus
en plus insistantes
on nous en demande encore plus parce que
l'organisation de mes clients fait que
n'ayant plus de visibilité du jour au
lendemain je peux avoir à gérer des flux
de pièces que je ne savais pas anticipé
au préalable alors qu'aujourd'hui ça
devient un quotidien que de gérer de
l'urgence à moi je reste optimiste mais
c'est compliqué